Welcome, students,
to Clinical
Pharmacokinetics,
Part 2. As I said in
Part 1, actually,
this is one lecture
because all of
the concepts are
integrated. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Same learning
objectives for
this part because,
as I said,
yet again, it
is one lecture.
suggestions and links
if you care to use
them the no one
understand is in part one
so let us begin with
the half-life half-life
is the time required
to reduce the amount
of drug in the body
by one half during
elimination. In other
words, drug concentration
decreases by 50%
in drugs that have
first order kinetics,
which is by far 99.9999
% of them at therapeutic
concentrations.
Half-life equals,
this is a constant,
an elimination
constant, 0.693.
Some people just move
it to 0.7 just to
be able to do calculations
in their head.
Times the volume
of distribution
divided by clearance.
So half-life is inversely
proportional
to clearance.
Clearance
decreases, half-life
increases. In other
words, it takes
longer to
eliminate the drug.
Half-life changes is
a function of both
clearance and volume
of distribution.
What do we use this
for? It is an indicator
of the time required
to reach steady state,
that dynamic equilibrium
point, the time
required for drug to be
removed from the body,
and a way to
estimate the dosing
interval. How often
do we want to be
giving a particular
drug to the patient
to maintain the
levels within
the therapeutic
concentration range?
Half-life depends
on both the rate of
elimination and volume
of distribution.
That can never be
said too often.
First order elimination
and zero order
elimination. Zero
order elimination is
frequently called
capacity limited because
the capacity has
been reached and
therefore we get zero
order elimination.
But first order,
as I said before,
the vast majority of
drugs in therapeutic
concentrations exhibit
first-order elimination
kinetics. A constant
proportion or a
fraction of the drug
is eliminated in a
given amount of time.
These drugs, drugs with
first-order elimination,
demonstrate linear
elimination.
The rate of drug
metabolism is
directly proportional
to the free drug
concentration, of
course, and the
fraction that is
removed is constant.
Talking about
constant rate
of removal of the drug.
Time points at
which blood samples
were taken and drug
levels measured.
This is exactly the same,
but it is on
semi-log paper.
concentrations are
in logs the log dose
and that just
straightens out the slope
it is otherwise
identical in this example
I'll use this example
here there There is
100, whatever it is,
100 units, 100%, and
50% occurs at this
point, and this point
is 4 hours.
So the drug
concentration has been
reduced by one half
in four hours. So the
half-life of this
drug is four hours.
So let's say this
is 100 milligrams
because I want
to make a point.
Let's say this
is 50 milligrams,
half of it, of course.
Well, in another
four hours, so
that would be this
point right here,
sorry my what
is this this is like
right about here
so that would be 25
25 milligrams still
one half but a
different number of
milligrams and another
four hours it's going
to be 12 and a half,
and another four
hours is going to be
six and a quarter.
Half, half, half, half,
half, that's constant.
It is the number
of milligrams
that actually go out
that is decreasing
by half with
each half-life.
Zero-order kinetics,
or capacity
-limited kinetics, means
that the clearance
mechanisms have
become saturated.
Let's say they're
enzymes. Let's say they're
hepatic enzymes and
those enzymes are
all busy. They all
are metabolizing drug.
The maximum velocity
has been reached.
Those enzymes
cannot metabolize
drug any faster
than they're doing.
As the dosing
rate approaches
Vmax, maximum velocity,
the dosing
rate approaches
zero, a disproportionate
increase
in concentration
will occur.
However,
if the drug is
continued to be given,
here's our therapeutic
range, and the dosing
continues beyond
the capacity,
it's just going
to go up, up, up,
up, up, because
the metabolism
capacity can only go
as fast as it can go.
So when the concentration
is way above
Km, this is the
Macaulay's constant, which
is the half-maximal,
the concentration at
which the half-maximal
velocity occurs.
So when the concentration
is way up here,
we are approaching
Vmax, and we're going to
be seeing the zero-order
kinetics. Now let's
say the drug
administration is stopped.
The drug is going
to be gradually
cleared out based
on however fast the
clearance mechanisms
can can clear it out
and the concentration
in the blood is
going to go down
gradually over time.
And when the
concentration gets down to
here, below Km,
then we're going to
start to see first
order again. Because
now the enzymes of
metabolism are not
at capacity. There's
plenty left over.
This plot shows,
this is on, the
concentration is in
logarithmic, it's
recorded as logarithmic
concentrations.
The, we see
the zero order
until the enzymes
of metabolism
become freer,
they're no longer at
maximum velocity,
then we get our first
order kinetics
right here in this,
according to this
graph in this range.
Saturable elimination,
here are clinical
correlates. Why do we
care? If the dosing rate
exceeds the elimination
capacity, steady
state cannot be achieved.
The concentration
will keep rising as long
as dosing continues.
Changing the
dosing rate for a
drug with non
-linear kinetics
is difficult and
unpredictable.
With first order, it's
easy. So let's say we
have a particular
plasma concentration and
it's too low, it's
below the therapeutic
range we want to say
double the dose to get it
into therapeutic range
we will double the
concentration double
the concentration double
the dose that's linear
with drugs that are
at uh will have
zero order kinetics
and there are a few
which i've listed
here but in the
toxicity range,
drugs that normally
have first-order
kinetics may start
exhibiting zero-order
kinetics, so as
with drug overdoses.
So with our
drugs that have
zero-order kinetics
at therapeutic
doses, and we'll
use phenytoin as the
example, This is an
anti-seizure drug.
Let's say the
concentration is
below the desirable
concentration
for preventing seizures.
And let's say
it's here. And the
concentration that's
desired is here, which
would possibly be
double. If this were
first order, you could
double the concentration,
double the dose,
get double the
concentration, but
not with zero order.
You might end up
going way over, so
it has to be done
very carefully.
Most drug elimination
pathways become
saturated if the
dose is high enough.
We're talking overdose.
Multi-dose kinetics now.
This very simple
figure shows
that with
continuous dosing,
it takes, this
is 100% now, so
this is steady
state right up here,
it takes four half
-lives to get to
right here. This is
94% of steady state.
And at this point,
full therapeutic
effect will be
seen, full clinical
response. So we
talk about four half
-lives as approaching
steady state.
It takes five half
-lives to get to 97%,
And we see it's six half
-lives who are already
nicely at that plateau
at steady state.
Four half-lives
to approach steady
state, and we will
be seeing a full
clinical response
at that point.
Once the drug is stopped,
it's going to take
the same number of
half-lives to eliminate
the drug. For half
-lives, it's 94%
eliminated and this is
the asymptote down here.
And there will be no
observable
clinical response.
On this figure,
this smooth
line, would be IV
administration.
Nice smooth line.
It still takes about
four half-lives
to approach steady
state to that full
therapeutic effect.
If we are giving it by
intervals, so
interval dosing,
it goes still
the The mean is
right here for half
-lives to approach
steady state.
Drug accumulation
with a continuous or
intermittent dosing
rate is based on
the fundamental
principle of clearance.
Clearance is the
volume of blood from
which a drug is removed
per unit of time.
Clearance relates
the rate of
elimination to the
plasma concentration.
So the dosing rate
equals clearance times
plasma concentration
and if it's oral we have
to be thinking about
the bioavailability.
We always think about
bioavailability
but IV F equals 1.
Clearance of a
particular drug remains
constant although
the The actual amount
of drug in the
clearance volume varies
with the plasma
drug concentration.
If it's a 100
milligram dose that's
going in, and
50% of that is
50 milligrams,
it's still a half.
Or if it is 20
milligrams going in,
10 milligrams comes
out in one half-life.
It's still one half.
steady state is
the rate of drug
elimination equals
administration
this plateau right
here in the
therapeutic range so
let's optimize our
dosage our regiments
our drug regiments
using the target
concentration strategy
based on this concept.
Dose produces a
concentration in
plasma, which produces
a concentration
at the effectocyte,
which produces a
particular effect,
the size of the
effect, the intensity
of the effect.
So the basis of target
concentration strategy
is the assumption that
the target concentration
will produce the
therapeutic effect.
The therapeutic goal
is to maintain the
steady-state drug
levels within the
therapeutic range to
provide efficacy with
minimum toxicity. So
this is optimizing.
Optimizing our
drug therapy.
Target concentration
strategy means a
desired steady state
concentration is
selected and that's
looked up in the
drug monographs.
That'll tell you what
the desired concentration
should be and
therefore a dose is
calculated that will
be predicted to
achieve this value.
But not all patients
are the same. So
the standard dose in
the healthy individual
may not be right
for everybody. In
fact will not be
right for everybody.
Physiologic and
pathologic processes
may be applied to dose
adjustment in the
individual patient.
Drug concentrations
may guide dose changes.
And we remember that
the concentrations have
to be related to the
therapeutic effect.
This figure shows
a nice therapeutic
window here in
the shaded area.
The top is the minimum
toxic concentration.
The bottom is the
minimum effective
concentration. It'd be
nice to stay in here,
like right in here
would be really good.
This shows you the
intermittent dosing so
that peak concentration
does not go above
that minimum toxic
concentration and does
not drop below the
minimum effective
concentration. Another
dose, another dose, etc.
It stays right there in
that therapeutic window.
this is referred
to as the peak
concentration this is
referred to as the trough
concentration
trough concentration
the lowest concentration
taken just before
the next dose would
be administered.
Now, when we are taking
our blood samples,
we need to take them
properly. If we're
taking a trough
concentration, it must
be a true trough
concentration. It can't
be like right here
because that will give
us a false impression
of where we are.
So let's
calculate loading
dose and
maintenance. dose.
Loading dose, volume
of distribution
times the desired
concentration.
Dose equals the volume
of distribution times
the desired
concentration. The desired
concentration would be the
concentration at steady
state. And of course
we need to factor in
our bioavailability.
So the loading dose
relates the amount of
drug in the body to the
drug concentration
in plasma. This is a
situation in which the
patient has no drug on
board. What happens when
we give a first dose?
Well, it's going
to distribute
to wherever it
distributes.
Distribute to
the tissues,
it moves into the volume.
And that's why we
think about volume of
distribution for the
loading dose when the
patient doesn't have
any drug on board.
Now the maintenance
dose, so dose equals
the clearance times
the concentration,
or in this case
concentration
times clearance
is the same thing,
clearance times
concentration, factoring
in the bioavailability.
So why Why
don't we think about
volume here because
the patient will
be at steady state.
We want to keep them
at steady state.
So it's already in a
dynamic equilibrium.
It's already moved
into the volume
and now it's in a
dynamic equilibrium
between the blood
and the tissues.
So why don't we
factor in clearance
with loading
dose? because it's
got to get to the
volume first before
it establishes
that equilibrium.
So maintenance dose
relates the dosing
rate to the rate
of elimination at
steady state. Rate
in equals rate out.
This figure shows
us the value of
using a loading
dose. It brings the
concentration
right up to the
approximate steady
-state concentration.
The maintenance dose
is started right away,
and it will take
the four half
-lives to approach
steady-state
and full
therapeutic effect.
Loading dose is
going to be bigger
than the
maintenance dose, do
I want to point
out here. This
is everything
I've just said.
now when do we use
loading dose that's
that's the question do
we have to always use
loading dose no loading
dose may be desirable
when the state of
the steady state
concentration should
rapidly be reached a
patient is in an emergent
situation and needs
the full effect of
the drug right away
other situations that
maybe a loading dose
would be useful is
when the half-life is
really really long and
want to get the doses
up prior to waiting
for a week or two weeks
but not loading dose
doesn't always have
to be given it depends
on the situation so
here's an example
this is an example of
theophylline. Theophylline
is a useful drug for
causing bronchodilation
and helping people
with acute asthma attack
breathe. It is not
used very often because
we now have inhalers
that will do the same
thing. It is a very
effective drug with
a narrow therapeutic
window and potential for
significant toxicity.
But this is the example
that is in basic and
clinical pharmacology
and has been an example
used for many, many,
many, many decades.
So the avalan volume
of distribution
is 35 liters for
a 70-kilogram
person. So we'll use
our example of a 70
-kilogram person.
We need to always
factor in the weight
of the person.
The weight can
be ideal body
weight, actual
body weight.
What do we do for
an obese person?
That's an area
of investigation.
Right now, it's
still quite difficult
to determine the
correct dosage
for an obese person.
There are some
guidelines for it,
for some drugs.
So that's an aside.
volume of distribution
35 liters for
a 70 kilogram person
we'd like to bring
the blood levels
up to 10 milligrams
per liter and this
is a monograph drug
monograph so I
looked it up I mean I
didn't I took I did
double check what
basic and clinical
pharmacology said.
And this is also
from the drug
monograph from
the tables.
This is an
intravenous drug
so bioavailability
equals 1.
Loading dose, volume
times concentration,
desired concentration,
the volume
of distribution times
the concentration
that we want, divided
by 1 in this case,
and we come up
with 350 milligrams
intravenously for a
70 kilogram person.
Just plugging
in the numbers.
Now we have to be
thinking about when
what's happening
when we give a
loading dose, especially
intravenously.
Well, it can shoot
up to toxicity
concentration for people
who are particularly
sensitive.
An excessive
concentration may take
a long time to
fall if the drug
happens to have
a long half-life.
And toxic effects
may result from
actions at the
undesirable sites. Not all
drugs are so selective
that they act
on only one therapeutic,
only one target,
and that's the
therapeutic target.
Loading doses tend to be
large based
on this volume
of distribution
at steady state.
Rapid administration,
rapid IV administration,
that drug
level can rapidly
shoot up like that
and that can cause
some toxicities.
So let's talk now
about the maintenance
dose for this same
theophylline example.
The maintenance
dose is administered
after the loading
dose is given to
maintain the plasma
level within the
therapeutic concentration
which we saw
on this diagram in
a previous slide.
So let's say the
patient is being is
given IV maintenance
and that's going
to be clearance
times the desired
concentration and it's
IV so my availability
is 1. All right
where did I get
this clearance
number from a table.
Notice that it is
clearance for a
70 kilogram
individual. If this
person were 50
kilograms that would
have to be factored
in an adult.
So working it out
it's 28 milligrams
per hour for the
70 kilogram person.
But we're not
going to send the
patient home on an
intravenous drug
when we can give
them an oral.
So we want to switch.
So the maintenance
dose is the same
calculation, factoring in
the bioavailability
of the oral dose and
then we want to
think about how
frequently are we
giving the drug.
Theophylline oral
bioavailability is 0
.96. Yes, that's nearly
100%. And yes, in
reality, we would
just treat it as
bioavailability one, but
we want to make a point.
And this is what if
the bioavailability
is 0.33 as we saw
with the verapamil.
So the drug, the
patient's going
to be sent home
on an extended
-release theophylline
every 12 hours.
So there are other
choices. That's a
decision that was
made for this example
in basic and clinical
pharmacology.
So we plug in
the numbers. It
comes out to 26.88
milligrams per hour.
Well, they're not
taking the tablet
every hour. So that
works out to 322.56
milligrams per dose
every 12 hours.
Well, it doesn't
come that
way. So what do we do?
Do we ask the
pharmacist to crush
the tablet and
figure out 322.56
milligrams per dose?
No, of course not.
We use something that's
commercially available.
So rounded up in
the case given by
basic and clinical
pharmacology,
two 350 milligram
extended-release tablets
every 12 hours for this
70 kilogram patient.
Very simple math.
Theophylline has a
narrow therapeutic window
and considerable
interpatient variability,
and the serum levels
can be monitored.
The assays are
available and reasonably
priced, so it makes
sense to monitor the
theophylline levels
and adjust accordingly.
Now variabilities,
we've been talking and
talking and talking
about this is what
it says in the drug
monograph based on
generally healthy, in
people with generally
healthy the elimination
organs, etc.
But what do we
do in patients
who have various
disease states?
So I put all of this
in tables talking
about the effects on
various parameters.
So absorption
from the GI tract,
that's going to
depend on how soluble
is it in the fluids
in the GI tract.
It's going to
depend on acid-base
characteristics. Will it
be destroyed in an acid
stomach? Does it
need an acid stomach?
How lipid-soluble is it?
Do we need to
give it with food?
Should we give it in
fasting condition?
Can it be given at
the same time as other
drugs? What is the
blood flow to the gut?
Will the drug be absorbed
and transported
to the liver?
What is the GI transit
time? Is it going
to sit in the stomach
for a long time
and move slowly
through the gut, or
is it going to just
fly right through?
What is the functional
capacity of the
organs of elimination,
the liver and kidney?
Does the patient
have heart failure
or shock that's
going to decrease the
perfusion to the
liver or kidneys?
If the perfusion is
decreased, the drug
is going to be
delivered to the
organs of elimination
at a slower rate.
What's the volume
of distribution?
Does the patient have
edema or ascites?
If so, the total
body water is up.
And hydrophilic
drugs that
distribute in body
water are going
to need to be
carefully dosed.
What's the plasma
protein situation?
What's the tissue
binding situation of
the drugs? What's
the skeletal muscle
mass? Does the
patient have obesity?
If obese,
the volume of
distribution
for lipophilic
drugs goes up.
Aging. Decreased
muscle mass, decreased
distribution can
decrease the half-life.
We talked about
obesity. It's going to
distribute to the
adipocytes and it will
be sequestered in
the adipocytes and
therefore the half-life
can go up as it takes
time for the drug
to distribute back
out of the adipocytes
and be eliminated.
And pathologic
fluid, we mentioned
edema and ascites,
that can increase the
half-life of the
hydrophilic drugs.
Clearance mechanisms.
what's the capacity
of the cytochrome
p450s has the enzyme
of elimination been
induced so there's an
increased metabolic
rate that's going
to increase the
elimination rate
increase the clearance so
increased rate of
elimination so increased
clearance is going
to decrease the half
-life and reduce the
therapeutic effect.
Conversely, if the
enzymes of elimination
are inhibited, that's
going to decrease
the rate of metabolism
and decrease
clearance. So, decrease
clearance, increase
half-life. The drug
can accumulate and
that can increase
the risk of toxicity.
Cardiac failure, well,
we're decreasing
perfusion.
Hepatic failure, we're
decreasing clearance
because the liver is
not functioning well.
Renal failure, same
thing. The kidneys
are not functioning
well and therefore half
-life will go up in all
of these situations.
I'm sure you have
observed that
volume of distribution
and half-life are
directly proportional,
whereas clearance
and half-life are
inversely proportional.
Pharmacodynamic
variables. There
are a couple here.
Maximum effect
attainable in the
target tissue,
sensitivity of the
tissue to the drug.
The pharmacokinetic
variables far surpass
the pharmacodynamic
variables which
is not to say we
ignore them. Of
course not. But we
must be very careful to
properly dose our
individual patient
in order to
achieve the desired
therapeutic effect with
minimal toxicities.
So individualizing
drug therapy.
The benefits of
drug therapy should
always outweigh the
risk. The therapy
should be as
simplified as possible.
Genetics play a role
in the interpatient
variability to
drug response.
Prescribers should
be thoroughly
familiar with the
drugs that they
use and to use a
limited number.
All the rest
you can look up.
You need to educate
the patient on
the disease and
treatment. And you need
to be thinking about
shared decision
-making between you
and the patient.
And what's the
point of therapy?
It's the goal of therapy.
You need a therapeutic
objective. This is
the reason why you're
giving the therapy.
Choose drug therapy
on the patient
characteristics in clinical
presentation. determine
the appropriate dose
and dosing schedule.
Electronic medical
records and pharmacy
systems increasingly
incorporate
prescribing information,
such as unindicated
medications being
prescribed, potential
dosing errors,
drug interactions,
genetically determined
drug responses.
Please do not blow
through those. Look
at them, think
about them, and be
familiar with all of
these various flags
that can come up in
electronic medical
records and what
they're telling you.
Maximizing effect while
minimizing toxicity.
Measuring the
concentration of drug and
plasma has utility when
there is a relationship
with the concentration
of drug and
plasma and the clinical
effect. when there
is an established
target concentration,
significant inter
- and intrapatient
variability in
pharmacokinetic properties,
when there's a narrow
therapeutic window.
And certainly, there
needs to be a reliable,
cost-effective assay
available for
clinical use.
One well-done drug
concentration,
I will put a
box around that,
is more valuable
than any algorithm
that seeks to predict
concentration or
effect using patient
characteristics,
comorbidities,
or other factors.
Poorly done
therapeutic monitoring
may produce
results that are
misleading, and in
this way are worse
than having no
testing at all.
The duration of an
infusion and the
correct timing of
the sample after the
infusion are
critical to having
results that can be
assessed in the light
of published data
and guidelines.
The major use of
measured concentrations
of drugs at steady
state is to refine the
estimated oral clearance
for the patient being
treated. For the
patient being treated.
So, in summary, this
is a little scheme
of everything we've
been talking about.
The elimination half
-life is a measure
of the time it
takes for the plasma
concentration or
the amount of drug
in the body to be
reduced by 50%.
Half-life is a
function of volume
of distribution
and clearance.
Half-life elimination
curves track the
amount of drug in
the body over time.
In first-order
elimination kinetics, the
drug elimination rate
is directly proportional
to the plasma-free
drug concentration.
And this is the kinetics
pattern of nearly
all drugs used with
therapeutic uses.
Now, in zero-order
elimination kinetics,
the metabolic
enzymes eventually
will become saturated
as the concentration
of the substrate
increases. And the
rate of drug
elimination is constant
or a constant amount,
not a fraction.
And independent of
plasma concentration.
So it's no longer a
half, a half, a half,
a half. It would be
whatever rate that
those saturated
enzymes are capable of
doing. Let's say
it's 2 milligrams per
milliliter. 2 milligrams,
2 milligrams, 2
milligrams, 2
milligrams, 2 milligrams.
And it will
eventually reduce the
concentration of
drug in the blood,
assuming the drug has
been discontinued.
If the drug has not been
discontinued,
that concentration
can just go up,
up, up, up, up.
When a drug that
exhibits first-order
pharmacokinetics is
administered to a
patient continuously
or intermittently,
the drug will
accumulate until it
reaches a plateau, a
dynamic equilibrium,
which is called
steady-state
plasma drug
concentration.
The time to
reach the steady
state is a
function of the
elimination half
-life of the drug.
Four half-lives
is 94% steady
state concentration
and provides
a full therapeutic
effect.
If the half-life
or the dosing rate
changes, it will again
take four half-lives
to approach the new
steady state plasma
concentration. The
therapeutic goal
of the target
concentration strategy is
to maintain steady
-state levels within
the therapeutic
range to provide
therapeutic efficacy
with minimum toxicity.
This approach links
pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics.
A loading dose
rapidly raises
the plasma drug
concentration
to the target
concentration.
The volume of
distribution relates
the total amount
of drug in the
body to the plasma
concentration.
The maintenance dose
is administered after
or even at the same
time as the loading
dose to maintain the
desired steady state
concentration. The
maintenance dose
equals the clearance
times the concentration,
divided again by
the bioavailability.
Disease states may
modify pharmacokinetic
parameters and
pharmacodynamic
actions in response
to drug therapy.
Optimization is
based on in-depth
understanding of factors
that determine an
individual's response
to drug treatment.
Know your drugs that
you use all the time.
Fundamental
principles should
guide prescribing
of drugs.
Here's a little
flow chart
if you want
to look at it.
Suggested method
of design for
a rational drug
dosing regimen.
And that concludes
the lectures
on clinical
pharmacokinetics.